There are two main types of tests
you can add to your Android project,
unit tests and connected tests.
The primary distinction between the two,
is that unit tests run on a regular
Java VM on your computer.
And connected tests run on
an Android device or emulator.
In general,
you should use unit tests for
testing generic,
non-Android related classes.
In fact, since unite tests are run
against a mock Android STK
implementation, any code that
calls the android API will fail.
In this case, you should either use
a mocking framework like Makido, to mock
the appropriate android dependencies,
or use a connected test instead.
Additionally, you can configure
the testing options in your Gradle built
script, to construct the mock Android
implementation to return default values,
rather than throw an error.
In any case,
it's up to you as a developer to decide
how to best write your tests, and
how to structure your code in such
a way as to make testing easier.
Connected tests should be reserved for
testing logic that depend
on Android API's, or for
more high level testing like
integration and functional tests.
Remember, connected tests are packaged
as an APK that will be installed on
an Android device or emulator.
So there's typically more overhead
involved in their execution.
Both unit tests and connected tests have
their own source sets, named test and
android test respectively.
The notion of variants
extends to tests as well.
Allowing you to write tests specific
to your build type of product flavor.
The naming conventions for these source
sets follow the same pattern as for
application code, except for
the test or android test suffix.